hiya folks Maxwell here with another
gamespot news update where the latest on
watch dogs is that the main campaign
will take between 35 and 40 hours to
complete or more if you're really bad
the game when asked on Twitter the
game's creative director Johann Morin
said I would say the average player who
does free roam a bit will tend to reach
the end within 35 to 40 hours but doing
everything as close to a hundred hours
of course that's just the single player
campaign watchdogs also has an online
component as well Morin previously
revealed that watch dogs will feature an
eight-player free roam online mode the
game also includes a head-to-head
multiplayer mode where players will hunt
down other human players and use their
hacking skills to affect the world to
their benefit watchdogs launches may
27th for xbox 360 xbox one playstation 3
playstation 4 and the pc the wii u
version will come sometime late and for
more on watch dogs including Sean
mcginnises amazing piece on the game
titled hacking and hentai be sure to
head on over to gamespot com